You look great.
Thanks for coming.
Thank you.
Thank you for having me.
You know what, I was
thinking about this today,
you're 20 years old.
Correct?
Yeah.
But "That '70s Show" has been on for,
how many years did I say?
Six?
Six.
Going on its seventh year.
So you got that job when
you were 14 years old.
How did you do that?
I mean, is that even legal?
It's illegal.
Well, it's not illegal.
It's just that they wanted somebody
who's 18 or older or emancipated.
So I lied.
The story has been said before.
It was one of those things where I went in
and said I was gonna be 18.
[Conan] Right.
They didn't ask when.
So it was okay.
Like sooner or later I was gonna be 18.
Right, right.
You could have also
said I'm going to be 80.
Absolutely.
If I take good care of myself.
Wow.
But then when I signed the contract,
I was like, "I need a studio teacher."
And they're like, "Why?"
And I'm like, "Oh, 'cause I'm 14."
[Conan] Wow.
And then it was too late.
Then it was too late.
And then did you just say suckers?
Exactly.
Then I fooled 'em.
Do you have big plans
for your 21st birthday?
'Cause for a lot of people that's a...
Like they have like a
big, cool plan for that.
You know, I kind of do.
I don't really drink and I
don't really do anything,
so for my 21st birthday I
really wanna do everything.
So I wanna go to Vegas and just completely
go bonkers for one night.
Oh my God.
So the words out that
you wanna go to Vegas
on your 21st birthday, and
when you say do everything...
Well I'm gonna be with my parents,
so not do everything, everything, okay?
I'm still gonna be, you know.
So if you're bringing your parents
you're not gonna be doing anything.
No!
I'm bringing my parents but
I'm still gonna do everything,
rock and roll.
It's not like that.
You eating Captain Crunch watching TV.
Yeah.
Are you gonna have a little
drinky poo or something?
A little bit.
Yeah okay, I like to call it drinky poo.
Why not?
I understand that in your
home you have a piece of art
that's actually from our show.
Yeah, okay.
So here's the thing.
I don't like your tone at all right now.
I don't like any story that
begins with okay, yeah,
here's the thing.
Okay wait wait wait.
(audience cheering)
You better change this
whole attitude right now.
Okay, I really liked your show,
until, one day I was watching
the show with my boyfriend
and you know he does
those segments with like,
if they mated.
Right, right.
Our baby came out so ugly.
Well, that's sort of the
idea behind if they mated.
But it was-
Can I ask them to look
and let them decide?
Is that okay?
Go ahead.
We showed a picture of you
and your significant other,
Macaulay Culkin.
And we showed a picture.
Look at this!
And we decided to show what would happen
if you two ever had a child,
what would it look like?
Let's take a look and see.
I'm just curious.
(audience laughing)
That's a good looking kid.
[Mila] That's ugly!
Look at the baby!
Andy, I think you should decide.
Isn't that a good looking child?
I think that if they
really do make the Hobbit,
your kid's gonna work.
(laughing)
That kid's gonna work.
That kid's gonna get a lot of work.
That's what we're trying to say.
Yeah.
Now, let me ask you, I understand that
although you are Jewish, you
like to celebrate Christmas.
Is that true?
Yeah, I like presents.
So I'll celebrate anything.
I'll celebrate Kwanzaa, all right,
if somebody gets me a present.
So I have a tree in my
house, a Christmas tree,
that I bought at Kmart.
It rotates.
And it's my house.
Rotates?
What do you mean?
You plug it in and it rotates.
Okay, that explains everything.
I realize I'm the idiot.
It rotates, what's happening?
It's in a stand, it's
pre-lit, and it rotates.
It just goes in a circle.
And you just put it up at Christmas.
No, it's all year round.
Oh, so you have a Christmas
theme in your apartment?
Yeah.
Well, it started off because I
was too lazy to take it down,
'cause it comes in three pieces,
and I was like, ah screw it,
I'm just gonna leave it up.
And then it just became
like the theme of my house.
Like I have my Christmas lights up,
I have like the fake snow on my table.
It's really disturbing.
It's like July and I'm like, go Christmas!
But I still celebrate Hanukkah.
Right, you still celebrate Hanukkah.
But you know what I've noticed is that
I think that Jewish people...
'Cause I've met a bunch of Jewish people
who have said that they
also celebrate Christmas
and I think they do it
because it's kind of
easy to figure out.
You get the tree and
that's easy to figure out,
whereas I don't know as
many like Christian people
that celebrate...
Like I myself, I don't
understand Hanukkah.
I know there's a dreidel
and there's some cookies
and there's a...
I don't understand it either.
I'm like a really bad Jew.
I never really...
Like I said, I celebrate
it 'cause I get presents.
So many rabbis are angrily
watching right now.
I celebrate Christmas, I'm
a bad Jew, I don't know.
I want the presents.
I understand the...
No, I mean Hanukah's a beautiful holiday,
but I don't know what...
Good save.
Whatever.
It's a wonderful time of-
Your political career is still alive.
Well, no, my parents are
watching going, oh my God.
Well, don't worry, you
can make it up to them
on that big 21st blowout in Vegas.
Sorry about the whole putting
down the Jewish holiday thing.
Let's partay and do jello shots.
I understand you're very unhappy
about the bug man coming up.
Yeah.
Why wasn't I tomorrow with Brad...
And nothing against you.
Whatever.
(audience laughing)
[Mila] No, no, no, no.
No I understand, I wish I was on tomorrow
with him rather than me too.
[Mila] No.
No.
That makes no sense.
I know.
You wish you could leave your own body
and become Brad Pitt.
Yeah.
I'm living it, you're just hearing it.
(audience laughing)
(audience applause)
I know what you mean,
I know what you mean.
I hate bugs.
I truly, I'm so scared of bugs.
Like you don't understand.
I don't think anybody in this
world exists that's more...
I love birds because they eat bugs.
I don't like bugs.
You only like birds because
they destroy and eat bugs.
Yes!
I hate bugs.
You love the natural enemy of the bug.
Look, nothing against
people who love bugs.
I'm all for it, like...
Good save.
You're saving things left and right.
I'm all about saving things.
Hannukah, bug people.
Yup.
So bug loving rabbis now love you again.
That's the important thing.
Yeah.
Well, you'll be protected.
I think I'm gonna be
over in that area there
with what I'm told are some deadly bugs.
Great.
And you'll be protected over here.
I swear, if they come anywhere
near me, I will freak.
I might pee my pants.
I don't like bugs.
I hate bugs.
Where I'm from that's good television.
[Andy] Stick around!
Stay glued.
The 150th episode of "That '70s Show" airs
Sunday May 16th at 8:30 p.m. on Fox,
and Mila's new movie
"Tony and Tina's Wedding"
is now playing at the
Tribeca Film Festival
in New York City.
Thanks for coming on.
Thank you for having me.
Really nice to have you here.
Mila Kunis.
We'll be right back with the
bug guy, George Brossard.